The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's start.
So recapping what
we have been doing,
we said that many systems that
undergo phase transition-- so
there's some material that
undergoes phase transition-- we
could look at it
and characterize it
through a statistical field.
But my analogy in the case
of magnetization of magnet
will be noted by m that
varies as a function
of the position on the sample.
And it's a vector.
And this vector
has n components.
And we said that basically
we could distinguish
different types of systems by
the number of components of n.
And for the case of
things like liquid gas,
we had a scale or
density difference,
which is one component.
For the case of superfluid,
we had the phase
of a quantum mechanical
wave function, which
had, therefore, two components
when we included the magnitude.
And for the case of, say,
[INAUDIBLE] ferromagnet,
we had n equals 3.
We said that basically all of
these systems in the vicinity
of the transition point
where the field n of x
is presumably fluctuating
around a small quantity
and the correlation
lengths are large,
we could describe in
terms of weight that
was constructed on
the basis of symmetry
and a form of
locality which allowed
us to express the
weight in powers of m
squared integrated in the
vicinity of some point x.
Then the connection between
the different clients
was captured through terms
that involves gradients of m.
And higher order derivatives
are also possible.
And that easy back to deviate
from the symmetry axis,
we could add a term that is h.m.
So that was this
statistical weight
that we assigned to
configurations of this field.
Now we said that when
you do measurements
of these kinds of
systems, for example,
you will see singularities
in heat capacity.
And those in the vicinity
of the phase transitions
were characterized
by an exponent alpha.
Now the value of alpha, you can
go and look at various system,
you find for liquid gas
systems many different versions
of carbon dioxide, et
cetera, and other systems
that you would
correspond to n equals 1,
like binary mixtures
such as the one that
is in the first
problem set, correspond
to a value of alpha divergence
that is roughly around 0.11.
For the case of
superfluid, we saw
curves that described
this lambda point.
There is, again, a
divergence, or the divergence
is weaker than the [INAUDIBLE].
It is approximately a
logarithmic divergence.
Whereas for ferromagnets,
there is a cost singularity.
There's no divergence.
And the singularity
can be expressed
in terms of a negative alpha.
So there are these
classes, depending
on the value of this parameter
n, which are all the same.
And in our case, they are all
described by this same field
theory, with different number of
components of this quantity n.
So we asked whether or not
we could get that result.
So what we did was we said, OK,
let's calculate the partition
function that corresponds
to this system
by integrating over all
configurations of this field.
And this is actually
just the singular part,
because in the process
of going from whatever
microscopic variables we have
to these variables that describe
the statistical field,
we have to integrate
over many microscopic
configurations.
So there could be a
non-singular part that emerges.
But the singularities are due to
the appearance of magnetization
spontaneously.
So they should be reflected
in calculating the partition
function of this component.
Now what we did
was, then, to say,
OK, this is difficult thing.
What I am going to do is do
a subtle point approximation,
which really amounted to
finding the most probable state.
And that most probable
state corresponded to the m
being uniform across the system,
value m bar, that potentially
would be directed along
the magnetic field.
But there's only the limit
that magnetic field goes to 0,
spontaneously select
some kind of a direction.
But of course, this
m bar would be 0
if you are above the
transition, which
in this most
probable state occurs
for t's that are
positive at h equals 0.
While for t negative,
minimizing tm squared plus um
to the fourth gave us a value of
square root of minus t over 4.
Then our z singular in the
subtle point approximation
evaluated as a function
of t for h equals 0
is simply related to the value
of this most probable state
at this particular point.
And we found that the answer
was exponential of minus because
of the integration over space.
But everything is uniform.
It will be
proportional to volume.
And then multiplied
by a function
that was either 0, if you
were looking at t positive.
Whereas for t negative,
substituting that value
of h bar, gave us minus
t squared over 16.
Yeah.
So essentially, it's a function.
There is really no magnetization
above the critical point.
And you get 0.
Below the critical
point, what you
have is this quadratic
behavior in t.
So if I were to take two
derivatives of it, which
would give me something that
is proportional to the heat
capacity-- so from here I would
get a heat capacity evaluated
in the subtle point method
as a function of t for h
equals 0, which would be
either 0 or 1 over 8u,
if I'm taking this derivative.
So the prediction is that
you have an alpha which is 0
because there is no
power law dependence.
And what it really
reflects is that there
is a discontinuity
in heat capacity.
So none of the
examples that I showed
you aboved-- the liquid gas,
the superfluid, ferromagnet--
have a discontinuous
heat capacity.
So this does not seem to work.
On the other hand,
this discontinuity
is observed for
superconductor transitions.
So that's the state
of the affairs.
What we have to understand
now is, first of all,
why doesn't it work in general?
Secondly, why does it
work for superconductors?
So that's the task for today.
All right?
So the one thing
that is certainly
a glaring approximation
is to replace
this integration over all
configuration by just the one
most probable state.
But we did precisely
that when we
were talking about the subtle
point method of integration
in the previous class in 8 333.
So let's examine why it
was legitimate to do so
at that point.
So there we are evaluating
essentially an integration
that involved one variable.
Let's call it m.
And we had a large number that
was appearing in the exponent.
And we had some function
that we were looking at,
depending on the
variable of integration.
Now the most probable
value of this
occurs for some
particular m bar.
And what we can do,
without essentially
doing any approximation
at this point,
is to make a Taylor
expansion of the function
around its maximum.
So the function I can write as
psi evaluated at this extremum.
But since I am looking
at an extremum,
if I make a Taylor
expansion, the term
that is proportional to the
first derivative is absent.
I'm expanding
around an extremum.
The term that is proportional to
the second derivative evaluated
at m bar will go with
m minus m bar squared.
And in principle, there are
higher and higher order terms
I can put in this expansion.
Now the value at the
most probable position,
which is the subtle point
value, is a constant.
I can put it outside.
So essentially,
terminating here is exactly
like what I was doing
over there, more or less.
But then I have
fluctuations around
this most probably state.
So I can do the
integration, let's say,
in the variable delta n.
I have the
differential of delta m
into the minus 1/2
psi double m bar
m minus delta m bar
delta m squared.
And then I have
higher order terms.
And principle, those
higher order terms I
can start expanding over here.
And I forgot the very
important factor,
which is that this whole
thing is proportional to n.
And indeed, all of
these terms over here
will also be proportional to n.
OK?
But the first term
in the series is just
the Gaussian integration.
And so I know that the leading
correction to the subtle point
comes from this factor of root 2
pi n psi double prime of m bar.
And then, in principle, there
will be higher order terms.
And if you keep track of
how many factors of delta m
allowed-- delta m
cubed is certainly not
allowed because of
the evenness of what
I'm integrating against.
So the next order term will
be delta m to the fourth.
Evaluated against
this Gaussian, it
will give you something that
is order of 1 over n squared.
Multiplied by n, you will get
corrections of the order of 1
over n.
So very systematically,
we could see
that if I called the result
of this integration i,
that log of i has a
term that is dominated
by the most probable
value of the integrant.
And then there are corrections,
such as this factor of log n
psi double prime
m bar over 2 pi,
and lower order corrections
of order of 1 over n.
Basically all of these
terms in the limit of n
being much larger than
1, you can ignore.
And essentially, this term
will dominate everything.
So what we did over there
kind of looks the same.
So let's repeat that for
our functional integral.
So I have z.
Actually it is the singular
part of the partition
function, which is obtained
by integrating over
all functions m of x.
And for the time being,
let's just focus on the h
equals 0 part.
So I have exponential
of minus integral
over x, t over 2m
square, um to the fourth,
k over 2 gradient of m
squared, and so forth.
And repeat what
we did over there.
So what we need over here
was to basically pick
the most probable state
and then expand around
the most probable state.
So going beyond just picking the
contribution of most probable
state involves including
these fluctuations.
So let me write my m of x
to be essentially m bar,
but allowing a little
bit of fluctuation.
And we saw that we could
divide the fluctuations
into a longitudinal part.
Let's call it e1 hat.
And the transfers part, which
is an n minus 1 component
vector in the n minus
1 transfers directions.
And then I substitute
this over here.
So what do I get?
Just like here, I
can pull out the term
that corresponds to
the subtle point.
In fact, I had
calculated it up there.
So I have exponential
of minus v,
the value of this thing
at the subtle point.
And then I have essentially
replaced the variable m
with the integration
over fluctuations.
So now I have to integrate over
the longitudinal fluctuations
and the transfers fluctuations.
And what I need to do is
to expand this quantity up
to second order.
But that's exactly
what we did last time,
where you were looking at how
the system was scattering.
So we can rely on the
result from last time
for what the quadratic part is.
So we saw that the answer
could be written as minus k
over 2, integral ddx.
Well, actually, let's
keep it this way.
We have cl to the minus
2 plus phi l squared
plus gradient of phi l squared.
So this is what I did.
What we had to do was to
replace this function.
The only part that has a
contribution from variation
in space, and hence contributes
to gradient, comes from phi.
So from here, we will
get a k over 2 gradient
of phi l squared.
Then there is a
contribution from t,
and one that comes
from expanding m
to the fourth to
quadratic folder, that
are proportional
to phi l squared.
And the coefficient
of both of them
we combine to write
as cl to the minus 2.
And if I go back to
what we had last time,
our result was that
k over cl squared
was either t, if I
was for t positive,
or minus 2t if I
was for t negative.
Whereas, when I expanded
the transfers component,
what I got above
tc, for t positive
there is no difference between
longitudinal transfers,
so I had the same result.
Below, there was no cost
for these Goldstone modes,
and the answer was 0.
But essentially, I have a
similar expression, then,
to write for the
transfers component.
So this part amounts
to essentially
what I have over here.
And in principle, I can put
a whole bunch of other things
that would correspond to higher
order fluctuations, effects
beyond the quadratic.
But again, our
anticipation is that, just
like what is happening
here, the leading correction
to the subtle point will already
come from the quadratic part.
So let's evaluate that.
So let's continue.
So this is exponential of
the subtle point phi energy.
And then I have to do all of
these integrations over phi
l and phi q.
Now what I can do, and I already
did this also last time around,
is we introduced an
expansion of phi.
We said each phi
of x I can write
as a sum over
Fourier components--
e to the iq.x phi tilda
of q, and with a root
phi for normalization
convenience.
So I can certainly replace
both phi l and phi t,
just as I did last time, in
terms of Fourier component.
And then the integration over
all configurations of phi
is equivalent to
integrating over
all configurations
of the phi tilda
of q's, sll the
Fourier amplitudes.
But the advantage is that
when we look at the Fourier
amplitudes, the
different q's are
completely independent
of each other.
So this integration
over here that
was not the
one-dimensional integration
becomes a product of
one-dimensional integrations
when we go to the Fourier
component representation.
So now I have to
integrate for each q.
I have either phi
l of q, or I have
the n minus 1
component phi p of q.
So these are whole bunch
of one dimensional Gaussian
integrations.
Because when I look at
what these rates are doing,
I get e to the minus k over 2,
q squared plus cl to the minus 2
phi l of q squared for
the longitudinal mode,
and a very similar
factor k over 2 q
squared plus ct to the
minus 2, phi t of q
squared for the
transfers vectors.
I have a whole bunch of
these different things.
Now we can, again, follow
like what we had before.
The leading behavior is minus v
t m bar squared over 2, u m bar
to the fourth.
And then I have a product
of Gaussian integrations.
For each one of these
longitudinal modes,
just like here, I
will get a factor
of 2 pi divided by
k q squared plus cl
to the minus 2 square root.
And for each one of the
transfers components,
I will get 2 pi k q 2
plus ct to the minus 2.
And there are n
minus 1 of these.
So I will get that factor.
And then presume,
again, there will
be corrections due
to higher orders that
will be multiplying
the whole thing.
So the quantity that
we are interested
is, in fact, something
like phi energy.
So we take log of z.
Let's look at the singular part.
Let's divide it by
volume, because we
expect this to be an
extensive quantity,
just like this other result
was proportional to n.
And let's put a minus
sign-- typically
you have to change
sign in any case--
so that the leading term
then becomes this tm squared
plus um to the fourth,
which, let me remind you,
is-- actually,
let's just write it.
tm bar squared over 2 plus
u m bar to the fourth.
And then when I take the
log, this product over q
will go to a sum over q.
And the sum over q in
the continuum limit,
I will replace by v integral
over q divided by 3 pi
to the d.
So then the next
step of the process,
I will have a sum
over q which I replace
with v times the integration.
But the volume will go
away, and what I'm left with
is the integration.
So I have the integral
vdq 2 pi to the d.
And I have the log of whatever
is appearing over here.
So what I have
there is log of k q
squared plus k cl to
the minus 2 with 1/2.
Why the 1/2?
Because it's the square root.
I take it to the
exponential because it
becomes one half of the log.
In fact, it is in
the denominator.
So there's a minus sign.
And the minus sign cancels
the minus sign out here.
And then the next term from
the transfers component,
I will get n minus 1
over 2, integral dbq 2 pi
to the d log of kq squared
plus kct to the minus 2.
And presumably, if I go ahead
with higher and higher order
corrections, there
will be other things.
Yes, Carter.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No.
It's just, like
the subtle point,
I'm trying to calculate
a systematic expansion
around the subtle point.
So I've calculated so far
the lowest order term,
although I haven't explicitly
told you what its behavior is.
Once I'm satisfied with what
kind of connection that this,
I need to go beyond and include
higher and higher order terms,
and maybe show you that they
are explicitly unimportant,
like they are in the
ordinary subtle point,
or that they are important.
At this stage, we are agnostic.
We don't say anything.
One thing to note--
of course, there
are all of these
factors of 2 pi.
Now if you go to a
mathematician and show them
a functional integral, they
say it's an undefined quantity.
And part of the reason
for undefined quantity
is, well, how many factors
of 2 pi do you have?
And what are the limits
of this integration?
So from the perspective
of mathematics,
a functional
integral is something
that is very sick
and ill-behaved.
In our case, there
is no problem,
because we know that our
field, although I wrote it
as a continuous
function, it is really
a continuous function that
has a limited set of Fourier
components.
This product over
q will not extend
to arbitrary short wavelength.
There's a characteristic
wavelength
which is the scale over which
I did the coarse graining,
and I don't have
anything beyond that.
So these are finite
number of Fourier modes
that I'm integrating here.
There is a finite number of 2,
2 pi, et cetera, that one has.
All right.
So fine, so this
is the behavior.
Again, I have looked only
as a function of t setting h
equals to 0.
I didn't include
the effect of h.
And let's explicitly look at
what these things are for t
positive that I will write
above, and t negative
that I will write below.
We saw that above, this is 0.
Below, it is minus
t squared over 16u.
That this quantity kcl to
the minus 2, it is t above
and it is minus 2t below.
This quantity kc to the minus t
squared is t above and 0 below.
Why do I bother to write that?
Because I want to go and address
this question of heat capacity.
And we said that heat
capacity is ultimately
related to taking two
derivatives of this log c
singular with respect
to temperature and beta
and all of that.
But let's write it
as a proportionality.
It goes like this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So the third
line on the top board,
you have under this continuous
product over all elements of q.
PROFESSOR: So this
product over q
goes all the way to the
end of the line, yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So can [INAUDIBLE]
be in the exponents,
or are they still outside?
PROFESSOR: What infinitesimals?
AUDIENCE: d phi l and d phi t.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
what I have left out,
and you're quite
right, is the integral.
So for each q, I have
to do n integrations
over this variable and
this n minus 1 component.
So I forgot the integral
sign, so that's correct.
All right.
So what do we have?
So for t positive, if I take two
derivative of this with respect
to t-- and actually there is
a minus sign involved here,
sorry.
Above the transition,
I will get 0.
Below the transition, I
will get this 1 over 8u.
So this is the discontinuity
that I had calculated before.
Now above the transition,
I have to take
a derivative of log of tkq
squared plus t with respect
to t.
Taking the derivative
of log will give me
1 over its argument.
Taking the second
derivative will give me
the argument squared.
Because of the minus sign, I
forget about the minus sign.
So two derivatives of this
object with respect to t
will bring down a factor of
kq squared plus t squared.
And I have to
integrate that over q.
And there is one from here, and
there's n minus 1 from here.
So there is a total
of n over 2 of that.
Below the transition, I
have to take a derivative,
except that plus thing is
replaced with minus 2t.
So every time I
take a derivative,
I will get an
additional factor of 2.
So rather than 1/2, I will
end up with 2 integral over q
2 pi to the d 1 over kq
squared minus 2t squared
from the longitudinal part.
And the transfers part
has no t dependence,
so it doesn't contribute.
So the entire
thing, you can see,
is what I had calculated
at the subtle point.
And to this order in expansions
around the subtle point, which
corresponds, essentially,
only to the quadratic part,
I have found a correction.
And generically, we see
that these corrections
are proportional to an
integral over q 2 pi to the d.
I can actually
pull out one factor
of k squared outside so that the
integral more looks more nice
with some characteristic
lengths scale, which is either
coming from t or from minus 2t.
So I can write it as cl squared.
So in order to understand how
important these corrections
are-- and here the corrections
were under control.
So really, I'm asking question,
are these corrections small
compared to what I
started in the same sense
that log n is small
compared to n?
Well, what I need to
do is to understand
how this integral behaves.
There is no factor
of log n versus n,
because you can see
both of those terms
have the factor of volume.
So the issue is not that you
have something like square,
log of the volume that will
give you small quantity.
You have to hope
that for some reason
or other this whole integral
here is not important.
So if I look at the integrand--
well, I can do one more thing.
I can note that it behaves
as 1 over k squared.
There is a combination
that you will
see appearing many, many
times in this course.
Because this is
spherically symmetric,
I can write it as
some solid angle q
to the d minus 1 with q.
And so the whole thing is
proportional to the ratio
of solid angle divided by 2 pi
to the d, which will occur so
many times in this course that
we will give it a name k sub d.
And then the eventual
integral is simply
an integral over one variable
q, q to the d minus 1.
And then I have q squared
plus c to the minus 2 squared.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Should that 1
over kd be 1 over k squared?
PROFESSOR: There is a q
over k-- Yeah, that's right.
I already had it.
Yes, 1 over k squared.
And then there's 1 over k.
Thank you.
So how does this
integrand look like,
the thing that I
have to integrate?
As a function of q,
I have to integrate
a function that at
least that small q has
no problem of singularity,
divergence, et cetera.
It is simply q to
the minus something
with the coefficient
that is like c.
At large distances, however,
let's say three dimensions,
it would fall off as q to the
power of d minus 1 minus 4.
At large q, I can ignore
whatever is from here
and just look at
the powers of q.
But then if I'm at
sufficiently large dimension,
the function will keep growing.
So basically, depending
on which dimensions
you are, and the borderline
dimension is clearly for,
it's an integration
that you can either
perform without any difficulty
going all the way to infinity
in q, or you have to worry
about the upper column.
OK?
So if you are in
dimensions greater than 4,
what you find is that this cf
in dimensions that are larger
than 4, as you go to
larger and larger q,
you are integrating
something that
is getting bigger and bigger.
And you have to worry
about that being infinity.
Except, as I told you,
we don't have any worries
about infinity,
because our q has
to be cut off by the inverse of
the character wavelength, which
is the length scale over which
I am doing the coarse grain.
So let's call that cut
off lambda, presumably
this inverse of some kind
of lattice-like spacing.
It's not the lattice spacing.
It's the coarse graining scale.
So if I'm doing this,
then this integral,
I can really forget about
what's happening here.
Most of the integral
contribution
will come from the large
lambda, and so the answer
will be proportional
to 1 over k squared
and whatever this
other cut off is
raised to the
power of t minus 4.
It's proportion.
I don't care about constants
of proportionality, et cetera.
However, if I am at dimensions
that is 3 less than 4,
any dimension less than 4, I can
as well say the upper cut off
go all the way to infinity,
because the contribution that I
get by replacing
lambda to infinity
is going to be very small.
So then it becomes like
a definite integral.
And it becomes more
like a definite integral
if I scale q by c inverse.
And then what you have to do
is you have 1 over k squared.
You have c inverse to
the power of t minus 4
or c to the power of
4 minus t, and then
some definite integral,
which is 0 to infinity dx,
x to the d minus 1 divided by x
squared plus 1 to the squared.
I don't really care
what the number is.
It's just some number that
goes in this proportionality.
So this is what happens
for d less than 4.
So let's see what
all of this means.
So we are trying to understand
the behavior of the heat
capacity of the system as a
function of this parameter t.
And actually, only the
part that corresponds
to integrating the
magnetization field.
As I said, there's
phonon contributions,
all kinds of other
phonon contributions
that give you some
kind of a background.
Let's subtract that background
and see what we have.
So what we have is that
from the subtle point part,
we get this continuity.
So let's draw the
subtle point part.
So the subtle point
part is-- oops.
Wrong direction.
Above 0, it's 0.
Below 0, it jumps to 1 over 8u.
So it's a behavior such as this.
So this part is the c
of the subtle point.
But to that, I have
to add a correction.
So let's look at the correction.
First of all, if I'm
looking at the correction
above four dimensions,
whether I'm above or below,
I have to add one
of these quantities.
These quantities don't have
any explicit dependence
on t itself.
So what happens is that if
I add that, presumably there
is a correction that I will
get from below and a correction
that I will get from above.
So this is cf for d
that is larger than 4.
So what it certainly does is
when I add this part to what
I had before, I will change the
magnitude of the discontinuity.
But so what?
The discontinuity itself was not
something that was important,
because u was not
a universal number.
So there was some singularity
before, some singularity above.
We see that the corrections
for dimensions greater than 4
do not change the qualitative
statement that the heat
capacity should have
a discontinuity.
But if I go to
dimensions less than 4
and I realize that my c goes
like the square root of t--
there is the formulas for c over
there, or t to the minus 1/2--
we find that this quantity
is proportional to t
to the minus 4 minus d over 2.
So below four
dimensions, what we get
is that the correction
that we calculated
is actually divergent.
So this is cf for d less than 4.
There is a divergence as t
goes to 0 that, let's say,
if you're sitting
three dimensions
would be an exponent
t to the minus 1/2.
So you started with a
subtle point prediction
that the heat capacity
should be discontinuous.
You add the analog
of these corrections
to the subtle point
calculation, and you
find that the correction is
much, much more important
than the original discontinuity.
It completely changes
your conclusions.
So once we go beyond
this approximation
that we did over here,
the subtle point,
and the difference between
our problematic and the one
that we did in 8 333 is that
we don't have one variable
that we are integrating.
We are integrating
over fluctuations
over the entirety of the system.
And we see that
these fluctuations
over the entirety of the system
are so severe, at least close
to the transition point,
that they completely
invalidate the results that
you had from the subtle point.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So obviously you have
some high order [INAUDIBLE].
And here you're basically
completing [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: Is there
an easy way to argue
that for b greater than
4 there is no divergence
lurking in the
higher order terms?
PROFESSOR: Actually,
the answer is no.
If I look at this integral
that I have over here,
it depends on t.
If I take sufficiently
high derivatives of it,
I will encounter a singularity.
So indeed, what I
have focused here
is at the level of
the heat capacity.
But if I were to look at the
fifth derivative of the phi
energy, I will
see singularities.
AUDIENCE: No, I'm talking
about the second derivative
for higher order terms.
PROFESSOR: These higher
order terms, the phis?
OK, all right.
So that was my next one.
So you may be tempted to say,
OK, I found the divergence.
Let's say that the heat capacity
diverges with exponent of 1/2.
And no.
The only thing that it says
is that your starting point
was wrong.
Any conclusion that
you want to make
based on what we are
doing here is wrong.
There is no point in my
going beyond and calculating
the higher order term,
because I already
see that the lowest order
correction is invalidating
my result.
AUDIENCE: So you [INAUDIBLE]
conclude that mean field theory
is good for bigger than 4.
PROFESSOR: From what
I have told you,
I've shown you that the
discontinuity in the heat
capacity is maintained.
It is true that if I look at
sufficiently high derivatives,
I may encounter some
difficulty in justifying
why d greater than 4 or less
that 4 is making a difference.
But certainly, as we will
build on what we know later
on in the course, I will
be able to convince you
that the mean field
theory is certainly
valid in dimensions
greater than 4.
But right now, I guess the only
thing that we can say for sure
is that the subtle point method
cannot be applied when you are
dealing with a field that is
varying all over the space.
So we have this situation.
On the other hand,
you say, well,
if it is so bad,
why does it work
for the case of
the superconductor?
So let's see if we can
try to understand that.
Again, sticking with the
language of the heat capacity,
we see that if I am, let's
say, sitting in some dimensions
below 4, to the
lowest order I will
predict that there is a
discontinuity in the singular
part and that the fluctuations
lead to a correction
where it should be divergent.
Now it is
mathematically correct.
But let's see how
you would go and see
that in the experiments.
So presumably in the experiment,
in the analog of your t going
to 0 is that you have a
t that passes through tc.
And what you are doing
in the experiment
is that you are
making measurements,
let's say, at this point, at
this point, at this point,
and then you are
going all the way.
Now we can see that
there could potentially
be a difference, depending on
the amplitude of this term.
If it is like that, and I can
resolve things at this scale
that I have indicated
here, there's no problem.
I should see the divergence.
But suppose the amplitude
is much, much smaller
and it is something that
is looking like this,
and you are taking
measurements that
correspond to, essentially,
intervals such as this,
then you really
integrate across this.
You don't see the peak.
You don't sufficient resolution.
It's kind of searching for a
delta function more or less.
And so whether or not
you are in one situation
or another situation
could tell you
about the result of
experimental observation.
So how do I find out
something about that?
Well, I want the
amplitude of this
to be at least as large
as the discontinuity
for me to be able to state it.
That is, I want
to have a c that I
have from the subtle point,
which is a discontinuity that
is of the order of one
over 8u, so there's
at a discontinuity
heat capacity.
This discontinuity should be
of the order of this quantity 1
over k squared c to
the power of 4 minus t.
But now it becomes
kind of non-universal
because I really want to compare
things, compare amplitudes.
I know that my c is predicted
from the subtle point
to go like t to the minus
1/2, where t is kind
a rescaled version
of temperature.
So t is, let's say,
tc minus t over tc.
It is something that
is dimensionless.
And so all of the
dimensions should
be carried by some kind
of a prefactor here,
that is some kind
of a landscape.
So the correlation,
then, is a length scale.
There is some prefactor
that is also a length scale,
and then this
reduced temperature
that controls the
functional divergence.
Actually, I can read off what
this c0 should depend on.
You can see that c0 should
scale like k square root of k.
So then you can see
that this object
k scales like c0 squared.
So this scales like 1
over c0 to fourth power.
And this scales like c0
to the power of 4 minus t.
And then I have this
reduced temperature
to the power of
d minus 4 over 2.
So you can see that for these
things to be compatible,
I should reduce my
t to a value such
that this divergence
compensates for the combination
c0 to the d delta csp,
should be of the order
of some minimal value of t.
Let's call it tc.
Actually, let's call it tg to
the power of d minus 4 over 2.
Or tg is of the
order of delta csp c0
to the d, the whole
thing to the power of 2
divided by d minus 4.
Let me wrote that
slightly better.
So tg goes off the order
of delta cp, delta csp
to the power of
minus 2 4 minus t,
since we are going to be
looking at dimensions such as 3,
and then c0 to the
power of minus 2
divided by 2d
divided by 4 minus d.
So we can see that the
resolution that you need,
how close you have to go
to the critical point,
very much depends
on this quantity c0.
It does depend
also on delta csp.
But we can argue that that is
a less important contribution.
Let's focus, for the time being,
on the dependence on this c0.
So c0 presumably
has something to do
with the physics of the system
that you are looking at.
So then we are leaving the realm
of things that were universal.
And we have to think about the
system under consideration.
And we have to identify
a length scale associated
with the system that
is under consideration.
Now if I think about
something like liquid gas,
well, one kind of length scale
that immediately comes to mind
is the length scale over which
the particles are interacting.
Also I can look at the
kind of phase diagrams
that we were looking get, and
there was some critical volume
where this transition
from one type of isotherm
to another type of
isotherm occurs,
I can ask that critical volume
how many angstroms it is.
But again, everything
here, we have
to try to be as
dimensionless as possible.
So let's say this critical
volume corresponds
to how many particles.
And let's take the
cube root of that
and convert it to a
length scale over which
these number of particles are
confined in three dimensions.
And what we find is,
for liquid gas systems,
that number c0 that you get
in units of atomic spacing
is of the order of 1
to 10 atomic spacings.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Scale on which atoms
interact with each other?
PROFESSOR: Well, it could be.
But for the case of, say,
particles in this room,
the range of interaction is not
that different than the size
of the particles
coming together.
It's maybe a few times that.
So that's basically a few times
of [INAUDIBLE] saying here.
And I'm not going
to argue whether it
is twice that or 10 times that.
It really makes no difference.
The thing is that
when I'm looking
about the problem of
superconductivity,
this is the only place
where we introduce
a little bit of physics.
When one is looking at
something like aluminum
that goes into being
a superconductor,
it is an ordering of
bosons in the same sense
that we have for liquid helium.
But the difference is
that what is ordering
in superconductivity
is not bosons,
but it is fermions or electrons.
And electrons have
Coulomb repulsion.
So what has to
happen is that there
is some mechanism,
phonons or whatever, that
gives an effective attraction
between electrons and pairs
them together into
a Cooper pair.
The characteristic
size of a Cooper pair,
because of the
repulsion that you
have between electrons, rather
than being 1 to 10, say,
angstroms, is c0 is suddenly of
the order of 1,000 angstroms.
Now note that if you
are in three dimensions,
this is something that is
raised to the sixth power.
So if I think of this after
dividing by an atomic size
or whatever, to a number that
is of the order of, let's say,
100 or even 1,000 and I
raise it to the sixth power,
you can see that the
kind of resolution
that you need when you raise
something large to a huge power
corresponds to t that is of the
order of 10 to the minus 12,
10 to the minus 15, et cetera.
And that's just
not the resolution
that you have in experiment.
So basically experiment
will go over this
without really seeing it.
Essentially the units
are so big that you
don't have that many of them
to fluctuate across the system.
The effect of fluctuations
is much diminished
compared to superfluid helium
or compared to liquid gas,
where over the
size of the system,
you have many, many fluctuations
that can take place.
This condition,
whether or not you're
going to be able to see
the effects of fluctuations
and something that is
[INAUDIBLE] field like,
I'll call it t sub g, because
it's called a Ginzburg
criterion.
So this basically
answers the questions
that we had over here.
For all of our
phase transitions,
we constructed the
Landau-Ginzburg theory,
and we evaluated
its consequences
for phase transition,
such as divergence
of heat capacity using
the subtle point method.
We saw that the results
worked extremely well
for superconductors, but
not for anything else.
And the answer to that is
that for superconductors,
fluctuations are
not so important.
And the most probable
state gives you
a good idea of
what is happening.
Whereas for super
helium, for liquid gas,
et cetera, fluctuations
are very important,
and the starting point that is
the subtle point, most probable
state, is simply
not good enough.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So when
you were giving us
the system of different phase
transitions [INAUDIBLE],
you only talked about
the critical exponents,
because, for instance, there is
a discontinuity of [INAUDIBLE]
heat capacity for all
phase transitions.
But it's often masked with
fixed singularity, right?
PROFESSOR: Once you
have a divergence,
I don't know how you would be
talking about a singularity.
AUDIENCE: If you roughly measure
the heat capacity further away
from singularity,
wouldn't it kind of
converges left and right
of two different values?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So if I draw a random
function that has divergence,
the chances are very, very
good that, if I go a little bit
further, the two
of them will not
be exactly at the same height.
There will be an asymmetry.
So are you talking about
the asymmetry in amplitudes?
Because I know the
amplitudes are not symmetric.
If I go very, very far away,
then all kinds of other things
come in to play.
There's the phonon, heat
capacity, et cetera.
So the statement
that you make, I
have never heard
before, in fact.
But I'm trying to
see whether or not
it's even mathematically
conceivable.
AUDIENCE: Another
question with this series
you just wrote out with
[INAUDIBLE] singularity,
doesn't it give you that
exponent for the singularity?
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: It's a
[INAUDIBLE] number.
PROFESSOR: It is 1/2, yes.
So there is a theory.
There is a mathematical
theory that
has this 1/2
exponent divergence.
What is that theory?
It's a theory that is cut
off at the Gaussian level.
So if we had some system
for which we were sure
that when we write our
statistical field theory,
I can terminate at the
level of Gaussian terms,
m squared, gradient of
m squared, et cetera.
If such a theory
existed, it would
have exactly this divergence.
But I don't see any reason
for eliminating all those--
AUDIENCE: So we still
have not found the reason
why the actual experimental
exponents are--
PROFESSOR: No, we
have not found.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So how do we
interpret the larger
signal of superconductity?
Does that mean the correlation
actually is longer?
PROFESSOR: Yes, yes.
AUDIENCE: But then
why are we saying
that the fluctuation
there is not so important?
We have longer correlation,
then usually that
means we have bigger
fluctuation [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so let's
see if we can unpack that.
So our correlation length is
some c0 t to the minus 1/2.
And indeed, what
that says is that
at some particular same
value of how far I am away
from the critical point, the
correlations are longer ranged.
If I go and look at the
amplitudes of the fluctuations
that I have, then I am
closer as a function of q
to a situation such as this.
So c0 is large c0.
Inverse would be smaller.
So that's correct.
And then in real space,
what it would mean
is that if I look at my
system, what I would have
is that there are parts that
are of the order of c0 t
to the minus 1/2 that
are doing the same thing.
Let me understand your question.
So it is true that
the superconductor
you have more correlations,
and what that means is
that the number of independent
modes that you have that
can contribute and
fluctuate is less.
And what we will
see ultimately is
that the reason for all of
these exponents being different
from what we have
in superconductivity
is that there is essentially
a much more broader range
of the influence
that is contributing
to the whole thing.
So I'm not sure if I'm
answering your question.
Let's go back and think
about your question.
So basically for superconductor,
certainly everything
that we said, including
being able to express it
in terms of this
statistical field theory,
having large correlation lengths
close to the critical point,
all of that is correct.
The only thing
that is not correct
is that the diversity of
fluctuations here is less.
And this lack of diversity
of fluctuations compared
to something like
liquid gas gives you
more subtle point,
like exponents.
AUDIENCE: So you mean the limit
for my integrand with respect
to q is smaller?
[INAUDIBLE]
So the q space I'm
integrating is smaller.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But if I calculate
fluctuation function,
something?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So this is what I was trying
to calculate here, yes.
AUDIENCE: Then it
should be larger than--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
But it is larger for a
smaller limit of q's.
So I guess what
you are saying is
that if I look at
the superconductor,
I will see something like this.
If I look at the liquid gas, I
will see something like this.
AUDIENCE: And [INAUDIBLE]
just intuitively interpret
what's the behavior of the
heat capacity from this--
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE],
because if you
look at something like this, and
particular its t dependence--
after all, everything
that we are interested
is how things change as
a function of t minus tc.
So presumably, when we do
that for superconductor,
if you do some kind of
a scattering experiment,
you will see some peak
like this emerging,
but the peak never
expanding as much
as it would do for these things.
You should be able,
based on that,
to deduce that the range
of wavelengths that
are fluctuating in
the superconductor
is less compared to
the liquid gas system.
And so there is not much range
in the diversity of length
scales that are contributing
to the fluctuations
in a superconductor.
AUDIENCE: So that explains why
we have only very narrow peak
in a cp?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
You have to go
very close in order
to expand the range
of wavelengths.
But then you go a little
bit one side or the other,
and then you are
passed that range
that you can see very
large wavelengths.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So in our subtle
point, the approximation
we found our maximum
when we looked
at the second derivative,
if we had considered more
derivatives, would we have
captured those exponents?
PROFESSOR: So if we
think about things,
and mathematical consistence,
here we have a parameter.
And we can explicitly calculate
higher and higher order terms
and how they are smaller and
become more and more small
as the parameter becomes
larger and larger.
Now what we have here is
the following situation.
If I presumably stick at
some value that is away
from the critical point, let's
say t of 10 to the minus 1,
at that point I
calculate subtle point.
And then I calculate
fluctuations
around subtle point, and
I add more and more term,
eventually, I think,
I will converge
to some value for
the heat capacity.
The problem is that I don't
want to stick to one value of t.
I want to see what's the
singularity as I approach 0.
Now we can see that
the problem here
is that this correction
gives a functional form that
is divergent.
And then I would say that if I
go to from t of minus 1 to 10
to the minus 3, then I'm less
sure about the first correction
and maybe I will do many,
many more corrections,
and then I would
get something else.
And presumably, the closer
I get to t equals to 0,
I have to go further and
further down in the series.
And so that becomes
essentially useless.
Now we will actually do
later on another version
of this problem, where
we say the following.
What I did for you here
was calculating essentially
Gaussian integrals.
And I know how to do
And for Gaussian theory,
this result is exact.
I will get alpha equals to 1/2.
Maybe what I can do, instead
of doing subtle points
approximation,
approach the problem
completely in a
different fashion.
I will start with
the Gaussian part,
and then I do a perturbation
in all of these nonlinearities.
That's another approach.
You can say, OK, I know
the problem for u equals 0,
and so let's say I got this
result for u equals to 0.
And I want to calculate
what the correction will
be in proportion to u,
u squared, et cetera.
But what we find is that
we start expanding in u
and calculate the
first correction.
And the first
correction, you'll find,
is proportional to uc to the
power of t minus 4 over 2.
So exactly the same
problem over here
reappears when we try to
do preservation theory.
You think you are preserving
around a small quantity,
but as you go to
t equals to 0, you
find that the coefficient of the
first term in the preservation
theory actually blows up.
So we will try a
number of these methods
to try to extract the right
answer out of this expression.
This expression is,
in fact, correct.
The difficulty is mathematical.
We don't know how to deal
with this kind of integration.
And I was just listening to the
story of Oppenheimer and Pauli.
And Oppenheimer,
when he was young,
goes to-- actually, not
Pauli but [INAUDIBLE].
And he says, I am
working on some problem,
and I'm not having any progress.
He says is the problem,
the difficulty,
mathematical or physical?
And Oppenheimer is
flustered because he
didn't know the answer.
So here, we know the
problem is mathematical,
because the physics is
entirely captured here.
We haven't done anything.
Now the question,
however, is whether
the mathematical
problem will be resolved
by mathematical insights
or physics insights.
And the interesting thing is
that, in a number of cases
where the problem originates
from physics, eventually
the mathematical solution
is provided also by physics.
So ultimately, people develop
this idea of a normalization
group that I will be developing
for you in future lectures,
which is how to solve this
mathematical problem, which we
have addressed from
this perspective.
We will try to approach from
the perturbative perspective.
And it just doesn't
work until we introduce
a more physical way
of looking at it.